now I'd like to introduce to you our
featured presenter Dan Binet Professor
Binet heads applied cryptography group
and co-directs the computer security lab
here at Stanford professor Bernays
research focuses on applications of
cryptography to computer security his
work includes crypto systems with novel
properties web security security for
mobile devices and crypto analysis
he is the author of over a hundred
publications in the field and is a
Packard and Alfred P Sloan fellow he is
a recipient of the 2014 a cm prize and a
2013 gödel prize in 2011 Dan Binet
received the ICI award for industry
education innovation professor Binet
receive his PhD from Princeton
University and joined Stanford in 1997
now I'd like to turn the floor over to
Dan great thanks Joe so excited to be
here welcome everyone and I want to tell
you a little bit about a little bit
about our work on crypto currencies and
blockchain technologies and everything
that we're doing in this space here so
I'm looking forward to this webinar and
you know if you have any questions you
know please please type them in and we
will answer the questions in the Q&A
session so this is this is meant for you
if I say anything it's not clear please
feel free to ask and we will answer the
question right away
all right so let's get started so as Joe
said I'm Dan Bonilla professor here I
work on cryptography computer security
and I've been doing a lot of work on
block chains over the last couple of
years that's a fantastic area a lot of
fun to work in this in the space and I
want to tell you a little bit about our
work and particularly what excites me
about about this area before we get
started I wanted to mention that in
computer science we have a very active
computer security lab which is covers
lots of areas within computer security
which intersect very strongly with
blockchains so let me just quickly
explain kind of what's what we do so I
work on on crypto blockchains things
like that
we have secure works on measuring
notions of security Matea works on big
data insecurity we have folks doing
static analysis which is actually quite
relevant
smart contracts or you want to make sure
that the contract actually does what
it's supposed to do and so we have a
number of people working on verification
of software in particular and smart
contracts as well david Nazir's works on
operating systems and consensus
protocols in fact the stellar consensus
protocol steller is one of the largest
cryptocurrencies out there that
consensus protocol was designed by david
monsieurs we have folks also working in
IOT security john mitchell works on
various aspects of protocol design and
programming languages programming
languages are also a big component of
blockchains again the question is in
what language do we write smart
contracts that are then executed on the
blockchain and that's that that's a
fantastic area that's that's growing
quite rapidly and then Mendel works on
VMs so there's a very active security
lab but in this in this webinar I'm
going to focus specifically on our work
on block chains and what we've been
doing in the space so what I'd like to
tell you a little bit about today is
basically a couple of things we've done
one thing I'll tell you about is
something called confidential
transactions using a system called
bulletproof that we developed and we'll
talk about all the applications of that
and where that's where that came from
and then I want to tell you a bit about
what are called proofs of solvency which
is how to prove that a cryptocurrency
exchange is actually actually solvent
and can cover all of its obligations
then we're going to switch gears and
talk about an application that's
actually not directly motivated by block
chains but is relevant as well I'll tell
you about a system called Creole which
is used for privately aggregating
statistics everything I say here is work
that's available in papers that are
published in public you guys all have
links that if you want to read more
about the work you're very welcome to
you and as I said if you want to use any
of this this is all public domain and I
would be happy to answer any questions
you have about deploying any of these
techniques ok good
so let's start with bulletproof and
confidential transactions this is joint
work with my student Benedict bonds as
well as our collaborators Jonathan
boodle Andrew Palestra Peter Woolley and
Greg Maxwell Andrew Peter and Greg are
in a company
block stream and they're actually also
one of the core some of the core Bitcoin
developers okay so this is work that
appeared earlier this year I have a link
here to the paper in case you want to
learn more about how bulletproof s--
work but let's get right to it
so I guess before I tell you about
bullet proofs I want to talk a little
bit more broadly about block genes and
cryptocurrencies in general it's it's an
area that from my point of view is a
fantastic area to be working is to be
working in the interesting that the this
area though you know kind of suffers as
you may know a little bit from overhype
but there nevertheless there are real
scientific problems here and just to
give you and that's kind of what
attracts me to the area kind of the hard
scientific questions that need to be
answered I can tell you that literally
every project that I talk to in the
blockchain space I walk away with three
new research problems to work on so
there are really lots and lots and lots
of open questions which is kind of great
for a researcher like me so just to tell
you kind of the the things that attracts
us to this attract us to this area so
you know there's need for new consensus
protocols when we'll talk about
consensus protocols in just a bit and
this is generally kind of work in
distributed systems so yeah so
developing new clean new consensus
protocols I already mentioned there's a
lot of demand for new programming
languages for programming smart
contracts and along with programming
languages for smart contracts has also
need for verification tools so how do we
verify that the contract does what it's
supposed to do so we don't end up with a
situation like the Dow where because of
a programming bug a lot of money was
stolen or like other exact like other
famous contracts were because of a bug a
lot of money was locked up so no one
could actually access those funds so
verification is becoming quite a central
area of smart contracts and as I said
there's there's a fair amount of work of
that on that here there's obviously a
need for new cryptography that's kind of
my bread and butter that's where I live
and that's where I'm gonna talk to you
about and then there's also really
beautiful work in what's called
mechanism design or more generally this
area called algorithmic game theory
which is essentially how to distribute
rewards in how to divide how to design
incentive compatible mechanisms that
encourage players to act honestly in
contribute wall to the system so all of
these are kind of wonderful areas where
the blockchain introduces new research
problems so there's really a lot of new
science that's being created here in my
opinion of course this area is like I
said a wonderful area to work in it's
not a fad it's an area that's here to
stay
and it's gonna be with us for a long
time as I said in this talk I'm gonna
focus on some of my work which is
basically kind of new cryptography
that's needed for for cryptocurrencies
yeah so I hope this will all be clear
and exciting to you and like I said I'd
be happy to answer any questions that
you have at the end of the talk so let's
get to it although I do want to say that
because of all this kind of scientific
interest it turns out there were many
people working on block chains around
the university at Stanford here and so
what we did is we created this new
center for blockchain research it's
called CBR the center for blockchain
research if you want to learn more about
the CBR please go to CBR that
stanford.edu there's a lot of
information there about what we do in
particular this is a research focused
effort but in addition to our research
we run a lot of outreach activities
including courses and MOOCs and books
and seminars so there are a lot of
activities all our activities are open
to the public and we you know we want
people to come and kind of join our
activities here on campus so you know
please go to see be our best Stanford I
need you to learn about our outreach
activities particularly if you go to the
seminar page there are instruction
there's instructions there on how to add
yourself to the mailing list just to
learn about activities that the center
runs I promise it's a very low volume
mailing list all you will get is just
emails about events that are open to the
public
that you are all welcome to come and
participate in in particular in January
we're running our third Stanford
blockchain conference if you want to
submit a paper to that if you want to
present some of your work you know their
instructions on how to submit papers if
you just want to come and learn you're
very welcome to as I said this is in
January open to the public and anyone
can comment
participate in the conference you if you
come to one of these events you kind of
realize there's so much energy in the
blockchain space even though it's a
technical conference it's really
fascinating to hear all the
conversations the talks and the
conversations in the hallway
and again I can tell you that a lot of
our brightest students now are going
into the space and with so much talent
in the blockchain area you know it's
almost guaranteed that good things are
gonna come out of it so I do want to
mention that our Center for blockchain
research is sponsored by sort of top
projects in the space the Assyrian
foundation protocol labs inter-team
Foundation of Michigan Michigan affinity
and polishing capital so it's been great
to work with them and as I said we're
always always looking for for more folks
to work with if you have any any
questions about a project that you're
interested in you know please reach out
and we would love to talk ok so with
that let's get started with the
technical part of the of the
presentation and I guess I'll start by
taking on a challenge that someone asked
me recently which is to define a
blockchain in 10 words or less so what
is a blockchain yes so let me try to
define it in 10 words or less and then
we'll kind of dig into the words so a
blockchain really is a data structure
that has a number of critical properties
right so the properties are basically
liveness which means that anyone can
write to the blockchain and there's no
way to prevent you from writing to the
blockchain right we call that liveness
like when you write to the blockchain
obviously there's sometimes there's a
transaction fee associated with that but
if you're willing to pay the transaction
fee you cannot be prevented from writing
to the blockchain so that's liveness
persistence means that once the data is
written to the blockchain it can never
be removed and typically the way we
achieve persistence is by replicating
the blockchain this data structure
replicating in many many times all over
the world so that if you're gonna remove
something from the blockchain you have
to remove it from all the replicas or a
majority of the replicas so that's
persistence and you notice there's a
little star there because typically
persistence is achieved under certain
assumptions basically say the adversary
has less than 51% of the computing power
in the net
work or there are other ideas that are
coming up about less than a certain
amount of the stake of the funds in the
network less than a certain amount of
the space that the network uses and so
on and so forth but persistence
typically is achieved under certain
assumptions and once you have liveness
and percent and persistence the other
important property that's implied by
that is what's called consensus which
essentially means that anyone that's
using the blockchain agrees on the
current state of the blockchain that is
we all agree on what beta currently
resides on the blockchain good so those
are kind of the three properties that
that block chains provide to us but
fundamentally I want you to remember it
is just a data structure for managing
data and it just happens to provide
these properties now these properties
enable a tremendous number of
applications the most us the simplest
one in some sense is a cryptocurrency
right if you have liveness and
persistence essentially this means that
if somebody sends you money there is no
you know a crypto token say there's no
way to take to undo that transaction
because of the persistence properties or
rather I should be more precise there's
no way to remove the transaction from
the blockchain because of the
persistence property of course you can
if you want to you can send the money
back and undo the transaction but
there'll be a log or the fact that money
was sent to you and then money was sent
back so persistence is kind of necessary
for a cryptocurrency application the
liveness property means that no one can
prevent you from spending your funds
once you actually decide that you want
to spend them okay so that's why a
currency is a very natural application
for a blockchain data structure but it
also enables a whole bunch of other
applications like what's enabled by
smart contracts it enables crypto asset
management so once I bought once I owned
a particular physical entity I can
record that on the blockchain and that
can never be taken away and until I
actually transfer ownership to somebody
else you can also talk about crypto
asset management for digital goods and I
have to mention there's a game called
crypto kiddies which which is where
people trade digital kiddies for fun and
it's actually a pretty pretty pretty
amazing game I encourage you to check it
out it's a really really well-designed
game where people can buy kiddies
and then trade them later on breed them
with other kitties and and trade them
and so on those are that's a wonderful
example of a digital asset that managed
managed on the on the blockchain
essentially who owns which katie is
recorded in this data structure and once
you own a kitty no one can take it away
from you even if the company that runs
the crypto kitties a game goes out of
business
yeah so you will always always always
owned this kitty and no one can take it
away from you and that's kind of the
power of the blockchain okay so a crypto
asset management is another application
I have to say that there's a lot of
interest were in the Stanford
Registrar's Office in putting Stanford
transcripts on the blockchain there are
a lot of benefits to that so for example
you can always if you if you present
your your transcript to an employer the
employer can always test can always tell
then it's looking at the latest version
of the transcript because the latest
version is recorded on the blockchain so
there are a lot of benefits to putting
contracts on the blockchain just for the
purpose of freshness so you know you're
looking at the latest version of the
documents and again even if you know the
unthinkable happened
happens and for some reason they you
know Stanford is no longer around your
transcript would still be on the
blockchain and you can still prove that
you are a Stanford graduate so again the
persistence is what is such such a
powerful mechanism that that makes the
data structure so useful and of course
everything is transparent the blockchain
all the data on the blockchain is public
the whole world can see it so there are
a lot of applications that require
transparency and blockchains are a
wonderful data structure for those just
to give you one example if you want to
run a lottery for example if you want
the lottery to be transparent so that
you are guaranteed that the randomness
that went into the lottery really is
unbiased randomness then again a
transparent data structure like a
blockchain is a very good is a very good
data structure to use yes so I kind of
walked through a number of a number of
applications there are many many others
but this is why there's so much
excitement about the space in that there
is this like I said there's this data
structure that's now available out there
it enables us to do things we couldn't
do before and again that's why so many
people are building new applications and
why so much challenge
going into the space alright so with
that let's kind of drill down a little
bit and I guess what I wanted to do even
though there are lots and lots and lots
of blockchains out there with very
different characteristics in very
different designs I wanted to just pick
on one and drill down a little bit more
just to show you how it works so you
know the one that I just I chose is the
Bitcoin blockchain maybe that's the most
well known but again I want you to
remember bitcoin is just one example of
a blockchain
in fact we consider just a generation
one blockchain in that it's very limited
in its capabilities generation two block
chains are things that are things like
if you um did include smart contracts
and other other other capabilities and
generation three block chains are the
ones that are being developed and
deployed now those are ones that kind of
avoid the expensive proof of work that's
needed to make block chains work and
we'll talk about that a little bit later
okay so let's talk about the Bitcoin
blockchain just so that we start at the
beginning
alright so the Bitcoin blockchain
basically is you know as the name
implies it's basically a sequence of
blocks yeah so you can add blocks to the
blockchain at will in fact every ten
minutes a new block is created and these
blocks basically form this very very
long chain yeah it's basically from the
beginning of time you know since 2009
these blocks have been added every ten
minutes so there are many many many of
these blocks and the reason they form a
chain is because you notice when I look
at block number n minus 1 that's the
block header contains in it a bunch of
transactions you can see there's a whole
transaction tree that's embedded in the
block in the block header this this is
what's called this tree here is what's
called a Merkel tree which means that
essentially all of these transactions
that we represent the block and we'll
talk about transactions in just a minute
essentially they are sort of committed
to in the block header yeah so the this
this value here is a hash value that
commits to all the transactions that are
embedded in this particular block
there's an what's called a nonce which
is related to the proof-of-work I won't
talk about that here there's a timestamp
but the important field and the block
header is what's called the hash so what
is this hash basically every block is
can it's in every block what you do is
you hash the block hitter yeah so you
compete some sort of a compressed
function of the block header and then
you write the resulting hash value into
the hash field of the next block and
this is what forms the chain structure
yeah so you can see here again block
number n contains a hash of block number
n minus one block number n plus one will
continue hash of block number n and so
we get this very very long-chain
structure where there's this dis hash
operation induces sequence among blocks
and that's what we call the chain as I
said this is only generation 1 of
blocked of the block chain structure
there are many new ideas being distiller
rather than using a chain people are
talking about using more complicated
graphs but here let's just keep it
simple and just talk about the Bitcoin
blockchain ok so that's what the blocks
are now you notice there are all these
transactions here so every block has a
number of transactions typically there
are you know between several hundreds to
several thousand transactions in a
particular block so let's talk about
what these transactions are and a
transaction again just to give you a
sense of how they work I'm not going to
talk about the specifics as a
transaction format format just to give
you a sense of what they are essentially
every transaction corresponds to a
transfer of you know potentially a
transfer of funds between between
addresses in the Bitcoin network yeah so
what happens is in a transaction we have
these inputs to the transaction these
are kind of the the addresses that
provide funds into the transaction so in
this case there are two transaction
inputs and then the transaction has
transaction outputs which are basically
where the funds are going so every
transaction output basically has a value
which is how much money is being
transferred to this particular address
and then it has the address which is
where the funds are actually going
alright so transaction outputs contain
value and address in this case there are
two transaction outputs we call these
things UT excels UT EXO spans stands for
unspent transaction outputs so here we
have UT Excel number one and UT EXO
number two okay so what happened here is
this transaction basically created two
new UT expose these UT excels belong to
you know
you know address number one in address
number two and each one has a certain
value associated with it now later on if
you want to spend money from a
particular address you actually don't
spend money from an address you have to
spend money from a UT Excel okay so
there are no accounts in Bitcoin no
accounts funds are actually held by
these UT exo's and what this means is
that when you want to spend money from a
UT Excel essentially you create a new
transaction here we have one transaction
input going in this transaction input
essentially points to the UT exodus'
being spent okay so the value that's
going into this transaction is the value
associated with the UT Excel and then
there's a signature by the owner of the
address that says yes I'm authorizing
the spending of this UT excel all right
so remember you have a secret key that
essentially allows you to spend the UT
Excel and only you can cause a UT Excel
to be spent or rather only whoever owns
the secret key that's able to create the
signature is capable of spending a
particular UT excel so it's kind of it's
kind of cool in that no one can take
your funds away from you other than by
taking your secret key so if you keep
your secret key safe no one can ever
spend your your funds and by the way I
should say that there's a whole industry
forming around custodial services for
holding secret keys for cryptocurrencies
so if you happen to own a bunch of
cryptocurrencies maybe as an investment
maybe because you're an enthusiast or
maybe because you want to use it the
cryptocurrencies for something the
question is always where do you store
the corresponding secret keys that
enable you to spend those funds you can
store them at your home if you want um
but if something happens and I don't
know maybe there's a burglary maybe your
home maybe something happens to your
house maybe you lose the secret keys in
some way those funds can then be spent
on your behalf and so there's a whole
industry of custodial services where you
can give them the secret key and they
will manage and store it for you so yeah
so keep in mind it's probably a good
idea not to store cryptocurrency secret
keys yourself it is probably a good idea
to give it to a custodial service and
this is their business to keep those
secret keys safe and make sure that
they're not
never lost okay so regardless so we have
these transaction inputs that basically
authorize the spending of aut XO and
here we have the you know two new utx
cells that are being created so for
example here you see iut excel number
three was created and the interesting
thing about the UT excel model is it's
again it's not account based so funds
are held in these uth cells which means
that after you spend the you TXO that UT
excel dies okay so no one can spend
funds from that UT excel anymore and
it's as if it never existed okay so this
would be called a spent transaction
output as opposed to an unspent
transaction output and no one can ever
spend funds from that UT excel again
okay so that's how funds are basically
held on the blockchain and that's how
they're being transferred from address
to address they're held in UT exo's and
a transfer means creating another UT
excel okay so that's the UT so model so
that's how the Bitcoin network works
it's a pretty interesting model although
I have to say other blockchains
actually use an account model where
funds are actually held in accounts and
if you wanted to see how much money you
have you basically check how much money
is in your account in in Bitcoin if you
wanted to see how much money you have
you have to sum up all the UT x so that
all the UT exo's that belong to your
address and that will tell you how much
money you have so it's a little harder
to tell what your balance is but at the
same time this model is actually quite
clever and that it makes it quite easy
to to manage what's what's live on the
blockchain and what's not live on the
blockchain okay so that's the UT Excel
model let's dig in a little bit and look
at a particular transaction so here I
just listed one random transaction from
the Bitcoin network and the thing that I
want to point out here which is quite
interesting is again you can see the
addresses here you can see the exact
addresses that provide the funds okay so
this is one address that provided the
funds
here's another address to the prize of
the funds and here's how much money was
being transferred in so in this case
it's point five bitcoins and then the
other address provided one point four
seven bitcoins okay so you can see
exactly how much money came in and then
you can see where it went right so it
went to this address
you know 0.01 went to this address and
then two bitcoins went to this address
so you can see exactly which addresses
in which addresses received those funds
and it can tell you that there's a lot
of work out there that shows that in
fact it's very it's not difficult to map
addresses to physical entities so
there's no anonymity in these addresses
it's actually not that hard to figure
out who these addresses belong to so
literally you can tell who transferred
funds to who and how much yes so the
amounts are all public so and you
remember these transactions all go on
the Bitcoin blockchain which is then
replicated all over the world and is
public for anyone to see and it's
important that everyone can see the
blockchain so they can verify that all
the transactions are legitimate we'll
talk about what legitimate legitimacy
means in just a minute
okay so the problem with this is that
this this the fact that all these
amounts are public is somewhat in is
somewhat contradictory to business needs
right so for example if yeah because
everybody can see who the payer is who
the payees and what the amounts were
this is problematic for business needs
right so for example if you know if
Stanford wanted to be my salary in
cryptocurrencies effectively in a
Bitcoin cryptocurrency say effectively
everyone could see what my salary is yes
so the salary would be public so that's
kind of you know contrary to what a lot
of businesses need it even worse like
for example if you know you wanted to
supply you know manufacturer wanted to
pay its supplier in cryptocurrencies
when Bitcoin in particular everyone will
be able to see how much the supply the
manufacturer plays pays for the goods so
forward for example we'd have to reveal
how much it pays for tires just as an
example so again this is gonna counter
to how to business these generally this
information needs to be kept secrets and
so the question is what to do so can we
adapt these existing cryptocurrencies so
that maybe it's okay too hot to reveal
who the pair and the piggy is but it's
not okay to reveal what the value is
right so it's okay to say that Stanford
pays me my salary everybody knows that
I'm a Stanford professor what's not okay
is to reveal what my salary is just as
this is one example yeah so that's our
goal so can we kind of hide what the
amounts are in the transactions and this
is what's called confidence
transactions some confidential
transactions is basically the idea of
instead of having the amounts be
available on the clear like you see here
the amounts are actually in the clear
the idea is to actually hide what the
amounts and yet make it possible for
everyone to verify their transaction
okay so what are we gonna do well
instead of writing the actual amounts in
the clear like we do here we're gonna
we're gonna write something else onto
the blockchain instead we're gonna write
what's called the commitment so what is
the commitment so here I have to do a
little bit a little bit of math here I
cannot give a talk without doing some
math so let's put let's let me explain
what this means so if you look at the
amount here you see it says zero point
five three three bitcoins instead of
writing the number zero point five three
three in the clear instead what we're
gonna write is the number five three
three in the exponent of some some base
yes we're gonna write G to the power of
five three three multiplied by some some
sort of a random value that hides what
the value is okay so this is what's
called The Commitments yeah so I'm
committing to the number five three
three which was the amount that's being
transferred but anyone who's looking at
the blockchain has no idea what the
number is that I committed to five three
three because this number has been
blinded by this random number here by
this H to the r1 where r1 is a totally
random number and I do the same thing
you can see this is a transfer of one
points four seven eight well I'm gonna
write G to the power of one one four
seven eight right so I'm committing to
the number one four seven eight but
nobody can tell that that's the number
that I committed to you and the same
thing on the outputs in one thing that's
interesting is actually that the fees
are still going to be you notice that
let me kind of jump here the fees are
still available in the clear so
everybody can know what the miners were
receiving but everything else is hidden
okay so let me just say a few more words
about this commitment this commitment is
what's called a Patterson commitment
it's a very basic mechanism used in
cryptography and when you want to commit
to a particular value v again like I
said you put V in the exponent and then
you blind it with some random number H
to the arm okay so by looking at the
number by looking at the commitment you
learn nothing about V
but whoever committed cannot change the
value
of the number V that's the idea okay so
now we get this private privacy more
privacy preserving blockchain in that no
one can tell what amounts were actually
transferred so again Stanford can pay my
salary no one can tell what my salary is
but now we run into an immediate problem
which is well if since the amounts are
hidden how do you validate the
transactions in particular what does it
mean to validate it validate a
transaction what you have to check is
that the sum of the inputs going into
the transaction write the sum of the
funds going into the transaction should
be equal to the sum of the funds going
out of the transaction plus the
transaction fee right that's kind of a
fundamental equality that has to be held
has to be it has to be true for every
single transaction when the amounts were
available in the clear everyone could
just look in the blockchain and verify
that all the transactions are valid if
the transaction was not valid the whole
block would get rejected and thrown out
of the blockchain but now that the
amounts are commitments they're not
actually available in the clear you can
no longer verify that this property
holds so we have kind of a fundamental
problem and the question is what do we
do okay so this is kind of where the
beauty of cryptography comes in and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
use a little bit of crypto magic and the
crypto magic we're gonna use is what's
called a zero knowledge proof okay zero
knowledge proof so what is a zero
knowledge proof a zero knowledge proof
is something that allows me to prove to
you that a certain fact is true without
revealing anything else about that fact
so you learn you have confidence that
the fact is actually true but you have
no idea about anything else yeah that's
kind of the magic of zero knowledge
proof and let me explain what we do here
so again even though the public doesn't
know what the amounts are whoever
creates the transaction can convince the
public that this equality actually holds
without actually revealing what the
input and output values are so that's
one thing so you have to ver convince
the public that this equality star
actually holds it turns out there's
another property you have to prove which
is that in fact it's not just about the
equality the other property have to
prove is that all the values are
actually positive yeah so it's not just
that the sum of the sums are equal you
want to make sure that none of the
output values are negative let me
explain quickly why that's so important
imagine I had a transaction they had
three inputs going in so there's a UT so
worth three bitcoins going in and then
one UT Excel and the output was equal to
7 and the other UT Excel and the output
was equal to negative 4 right so we have
3 going in 7 and negative 4 going out
well 3 is equal to 7 plus negative 4 yes
so star is satisfied however now we have
a uth so that's worth 7 bitcoins which
anyone can then spend as if they had 7
bitcoins yeah so money was all of a
sudden created out of thin air and of
course they've been ignore them the
negative for output they're just gonna
use the 7 Bitcoin output and sort of all
of a sudden money was created out of
thin air
so in fact proving that all the outputs
are positive is kind of crucial to
prevent money from being created and so
we have to do that as well the odd thing
is that proving that star holds is quite
easy proving that inequality like this
is actually quite easy this is just
follows from the rules of exponentiation
yeah if I have well let me kind of
convince you that that's true if I have
a commitment you can see G to the 5 3 3
and G to the 1 4 7 8 if I multiply these
two together I get G to the 5 3 3 plus 1
4 7 8 yeah and I can compare that to the
sum to the product of these two outputs
yeah so in fact checking that a sum
holds is actually quite easy checking
that a value is positive that turns out
to be kind of tricky why did I write a 2
to the 50 to minus 1 here well it turns
out that's the denomination of Bitcoin
yeah so a Bitcoin can go up to basically
the the it has Bitcoin has 52 bits of
precision for particular amounts so the
amounts can be specified as a 52 bit
string and we have to argue that that 52
bit string is a positive positive value
okay that's the hard part
all right so what do we do so our work
basically which we call bullet proofs is
a very efficient zero knowledge proof
system for proving that a commitment to
a value V is positive yeah the value
that was committed to in fact is
positive and it builds on some earlier
work again
beautiful work of bouteille Cirelli
China's gross and petite from 2016 we
basically kind of improved improved it
somewhat and and experimented with with
it
for this particular application and so
what we can do is essentially if you
have an n-bit proof in so you have a
commitment to an n bit number and you
want to prove that number is positive
this is what's called a range proof it
turns out again I have to write a little
bit of math here it turns out our proof
size effectively is logarithmic in the
number of bits okay so even if your
number is a you know a thousand bits the
proof will only contain ten ten elements
in it yeah so it's a very short proof
whereas previously the proofs were much
much much longer they basically we're
linear in the in the size of the value
yeah so we kind of went from linear
sized proofs to logarithmic sized proofs
logarithms of course grow much slower
but even more importantly if you have to
do deep proofs like if you have to prove
multiple ranges at in a given in a given
block remember every block has like a
thousand transactions in it and so you
have to do like a thousand of these
arranged proofs in every block and
before the size of these proofs would
just add up so if you have to do a
thousand proofs the proof would be a
thousand times bigger than a single
proof in our case using bulletproof snow
you just basically if you have to do a
thousand proofs all you do is you add
like ten additional elements and that's
it and then nothing else nothing else
changes and of course there is no trust
I set up which I won't talk about talked
about here okay so these bulletproof are
kind of extremely well-suited for
confidential transactions and then just
to give you an example essentially if
you wanted to implement confidential
transactions using the previous best
zero knowledge system if you had one
transaction the with a data that would
have to go on the blockchain would be
around four kilobytes
whereas with bulletproof sits only six
hundred bucks so even for a single
transaction we save a lot of space on
the blockchain if you wanted to do
proofs for like two transactions before
everything would scale linearly for us
things scale much much better so instead
of you know seven thousand bytes we only
need seven hundred bytes if you want to
do ten proofs you know here before you
would need forty thousand bytes we all
need we only need nine
hundred bytes okay so again the amount
of data that goes in the blockchain all
these proofs have to go on the
blockchain to convince the public the
amount of data using bullet proofs is
much much much shorter than what was
possible before in the case of no
trusted setup and as a result this makes
confidential transactions much much more
practical and easier to deploy in the
real world without blowing up the size
of the blockchain good so yeah as I said
this is the the bullet proofs are like a
very good match for confidential
transactions just to be concrete if you
wanted to implement confidential
transactions without bulletproof
blockchain would be like 160 gigabytes
with us it kind of drops to like 17
gigabytes so you know significant
savings and I want you to remember the
blockchain is replicated all over the
world all over the world right so
everyone would have had to store 160
gigabytes here we are providing quite a
bit of savings in the amount of storage
the other thing that bullet proofs are
good for is proving what's called
solving the solvency problem yeah now
explain this is a paper that we wrote in
2015 and how to prove that an exchange
is solvent and I'll talk about that more
in just a minute but I can tell you that
you know first results the proof of
solvency that the exchange actually can
support all of its all of its
obligations that proof was 18 gigabytes
every day would have been would have had
to be produced with bullet proof the
proof goes down dramatically to
something like 60 megabytes which is
much much much easier to do in practice
and it turns out a bullet proof can also
be used for providing other anonymity
mechanisms which I won't talk about here
okay so let's talk about a solvency
problem so that's kind of in a really
fascinating area in its own right so let
me explain what the solvency problem is
so I hope many of you have heard of
mount gorks yeah so mob GOx is a Bitcoin
exchange that essentially held a lot of
people's funds yeah so instead of
holding the funds yourself you would
give the funds to Mongkok sand they
presumably would store them for you well
unfortunately through a sequence of
mishaps they basically lost all the
funds that were given to them and just
so that you understand something like
450 million dollars were lost as a
result
of the month cost compromised this was a
big deal in the Bitcoin world you know
it caused a crash in the prices of
Bitcoin now this was kind of a very
traumatic event for for the for
cryptocurrencies and for Bitcoin in
particular but it turns out map box was
nothing special in that many other
exchanges have failed to basically
people gave them their funds to hold and
then the exchange is basically lost
those funds and a lot of people lost
their cryptocurrency savings and again
this is why you want to use custodial
services because this is their business
they will not lose or presumably that
they're built to not lose your your keys
so don't hold the keys yourself give
them to a custodial service that's the
probably the safest thing to do okay so
the question is what can we do about
these these solvency problems the fact
that exchanges so many exchanges have
lost the funds given to them so the
question is what to do and so again we
can you we can use the fact that we're
dealing dealing the digital goods to
provide what's called a proof of
solvency so what is a proof of solvency
in the physical let's see so every
exchange has a bunch of obligations to
its customers this is how much money
they owe their customers and then they
have a bunch of assets that they hold
right so these are basically crypto
currencies crypto funds that the
exchange owns and the goal is to prove
that the amount of assets is at least as
big as the amount of obligations in fact
if you wanted to support reserve reserve
currencies where maybe the assets are
only 1/10 of the applications you can do
that too but let's stick to the simple
simple case where just assets are bigger
than obligations okay this is what
solvency means in the physical world the
way a bank proved that it proved it as
solvent is it brings in auditors once a
year and these auditors certify that the
bank is solvent that is not a
transparent process not transparent
right nobody in the public knows what
these auditors do they just certify but
there is no transparency to that process
in the beauty of a cryptocurrency is you
can actually transparently prove to the
entire world that you're solvent because
everything is stored as crypto what we
would like to do though is prove that
the exchange is solvent
without revealing secretive from you no
internal information that's private to
the exchange
well this again takes us to the world of
zero knowledge groups where you'd like
to prove in zero knowledge that you
solvent without revealing anything about
your internal business okay so again
that was a beautiful problem for us that
that we worked on and as I said we
developed an efficiency or in-house
protocol for this problem yeah it's kind
of remarkable that literally the
exchange can run this protocol every day
yeah every day it would produce you
don't have to do this once a year like
in the physical world every morning it
would produce as urinals proof that says
yes my assets are bigger than my
obligations nothing would be revealed
about its obligations and nothing would
be revealed about its assets and yet the
public now is confident that they are
solvent yeah so that's what you can do
with these proofs of solvency is your
knowledge proofs of solvency and as I
said bullet proof makes this very
efficient it's quite interesting
actually if mom Cox had run these proofs
like on a daily basis their trouble
would have been detected many many
months before they actually had to
declare that they're bankrupt yeah in
fact they would have discovered
themselves that they cannot run the
proof of solvency and they would have
realized that there's a problem much
earlier on then when the problem was
actually in public yeah so I have to say
that bullet proofs have been adopted by
a number of projects and they're
actually put in use somehow somehow
proofs of solvency have not yet been
adopted by the industry so if you know
and if you run an exchange if you know
an exchange that's interested in
deploying a proof of solvency please get
in touch with us you know I think this
is a useful thing to deploy I think one
once-once exchange does it all the other
exchanges would have to kind of deploy
it as well and you know it would make it
would give us more faith in how these
exchanges run and so generally this is
kind of a nice thing to do and we as I
said we can do it so we might as well so
again if you're interested in actually
deploying and using this please get in
touch with us all the research that we
do is available in the public domain to
support ecosystem and in fact we'd be
happy to help you deploy this okay so
that's kind of what I wanted to say
about proof of solvency and
have to say I literally only touched the
tip of the iceberg when it comes to
cryptocurrencies it's a huge and
fascinating area all I told you about is
this one project that we did this year
we have many many many other projects
that we do at the CBR and you know lots
and lots of forward-looking looking
research that we do if you want to learn
more about the work that we do as I said
go to CBR destined for the ddu and check
out our research page and then in
addition we're also running a class on
cryptocurrencies and blockchain
technologies this will be the third time
we run this class we've been doing it
for three years now the class is called
CF 251 it's actually a televised class
so anyone can sign up to this class via
SCPD pass stanford.edu so anywhere in
the world you're welcome very welcome to
take the class either you know if you're
local you know come to our lectures and
listen in if you're remote you can you
can you watch it on the web the class is
gonna go through a lot of the issues
that surround cryptocurrencies
how the crypto works have the consensus
protocols work how to write smart
contracts what are the upcoming
technologies in crypto currencies and
block chains it's a lot of fun to teach
this class obviously the students are
quite interested in this and as I said
we'll cover a lot more than I was able
to cover here today so I look forward to
seeing you there now I think we're
actually running kind of this took a
little bit longer that I expected I hope
it was all clear I was hoping to tell
you about another project which maybe
I'll just summarize in 30 seconds and
then stop which is a way to privately
aggregate statistics and again I put up
a link to this project if you want to
learn more about what it does but maybe
I can just walk through in 30 seconds
and explain what this project does it's
kind of an interesting interesting topic
in its own right so I just want you to
be aware that this technology exists and
if it's applicable to you you know
please use it or get in touch with us
and we would be happy to help you deploy
it so the problem is basically how do we
how does a company learn about its users
aggregate statistics about its user in a
privacy-preserving manner okay so today
suppose let's take a simple application
suppose your Twitter you want to measure
our site suppose you're you're an
applique
that measures I don't know people's
blood pressure and you want to measure
you know how does blood pressure
correlate to how many minutes a day you
use Twitter yeah so every point here
corresponds to one user right so this
user uses Twitter this much and his
blood pressure is this much right so if
you wanted to kind of build a model for
how Twitter usage correlates to blood
pressure this is just a comical
application nobody actually does this
but if you wanted to build sort of a
model for what the correlation is the
way you do that today is basically every
user sends the data to the application
to the application developer and then
the application developer runs
regression to figure out what what the
model is yeah that's kind of how we do
things today this is highly non private
in the sense that you have to send all
your data to the application developer
even though all the application
developer cares about is aggregate
statistics okay so this is very non
private and the question is can we do
better and it turns out we can do better
basically what you can do is you can
split your data and share and send a
share of the data to the stress tracker
which actually reveals nothing to the
application developer you can send
another share of the data to say Google
which again on their own they learn
nothing about your data so this is
called secret sharing where each where
by themselves they absolutely learn
nothing about the individual data and
yet they can actually together they can
figure out what the model is yes oh this
is great yeah this is great allows the
the developer to learn what the model is
without learning anything about private
data however the Harvard is a problem
the problem is that someone can come in
and send you bogus data you can see they
send a point that's way way way way way
up here and that causes of the whole
model to skew that one point is so off
the charts that it causes the whole
model just queue and so what our system
can make it what system makes it
possible to do is basically you know
learn the results do it with privacy but
also make sure that all the submissions
actually are lie within a legitimate
bound a valid bound so you cannot have
one submission that will skew up all the
results all right so that's what the
prio system does if you have a need for
private aggregation
I'm not gonna say much more about this
if you have a need for a private
aggregation you know I would encourage
you to go check out this project this is
something that we did again this earlier
this year everything is available online
including code and paper that explains
all the system works and if you'd like
to use it as I said please get in touch
with us and we'd be happy to to help you
do that all right so I'm gonna stop here
and I will open it up for questions so
Joe take it away great well thank you so
much Dan for joining us and giving us
such a wonderful presentation
now we'll shoot some questions over to
Dan for the end of this presentation so
one of the first questions that came up
and I think it you know it definitely
stands out is why are machines being
used to generate Bitcoin hash so highly
power-hungry yes that's a great question
right great so this is you asking about
the proof of work so I guess this is
this is related to the consensus part
which would quite didn't quite talk
about here so let's see so Bitcoin uses
this proof of work mechanism so that the
more power you invest as a miner the
more likely you are to be minting the
next block and I should say that whoever
mints the block gets what's called a
block reward the coin base which is you
know essentially an amount of Bitcoin
that then you you as a miner own yeah so
the reason so the reason for this proof
of work mechanism is actually very very
very simple to understand in that
effectively it's a way to randomly
choose a miner from the set of all
miners in the system yeah so you know
everybody invests a certain amount of
energy in trying to solve a particular
puzzle solving that whoever solves the
puzzle is gonna kind of wins the lottery
and gets to mint the next block which
then pays back to that miner
okay so effectively a proof-of-work is
what we have come to call a randomness
beacon yeah if you have like say a
thousand miners then the proof of work
is basically a way to choose at random
from the set of thousand miners in a way
that no one can bias right so you know
everybody tries to solve the challenge
that was you know embedded in the block
and whoever solves it is the one that
actually gets the block reward
yeah so basically proof-of-work is a way
to to is one way to implement a
randomness beacon yeah that chooses a
miner at random but now we're coming you
know there have been many proposals for
other randomness beacons that actually
are not that power-hungry that don't
require burning so much energy so in
fact this is kind of as I said
generation one block chains require
proof of work the third generation block
chains are actually started starting to
move away from proof of work and just to
give you some examples there's a lot of
there are many experiments with proof of
stake so rather than generating
randomness by solving a hard challenge
we can generate randomness by basically
requiring everybody to prove mistake and
if they misbehave they lose that state
so there are several experiments with
that there's a beautiful just beautiful
work on using proof of space instead of
proof of work so a company called
project called chia is doing that proof
of space means that rather than proving
that you own a lot of CPUs you prove
that you own a lot of disks and this we
have a lot of storage and disks
themselves actually don't consume that
much power so it's gonna be much more
eco-friendly as it's gonna be a much
more eco-friendly way to generate
randomness to sort of choose a miner at
random in fact gia calls it farming
instead of mining because it's so much
equal more eco-friendly and so we're
actually gonna be moving away eventually
from proof-of-work
and these these this mining process is
not gonna take that much energy but
again to answer your question yeah in
one sentence essentially it's the proof
of work as a way to choose a random
miner that well then mince the next the
next block great thank you for that
another question and this come came up a
few times if the blockchain info can't
be deleted how was the mountain ox
crypto disappear like get stole well
well the information is still on the
blockchain we can still see that it was
stolen so it's not that the trend the
data was deleted from the blockchain
what happened was essentially there were
a couple of things that happened
essentially people were so mal Cox
people sent their money to their their
their crypto currencies to to mount GOx
mangas consolidated it
to their own assets and then
unfortunately due to bugs in the system
an attacker was able to withdraw more
money than the attacker deposited so
even though all the money was pooled
together
mount GOx paid out more than it was
supposed to to d2 the particular
attackers and as a result they you know
it's all recorded on the blockchain they
basically lost the funds that were given
to them essentially the funds were
transferred to other other to another
you know malicious user and so yeah so
the fact that the data was not removed
from the blockchain it's just that the
funds moved where they were not supposed
to move and follow-up to that if the
ledger is is always there and you could
see the transaction how are they not
able to identify who the attacker was
hah well that's a good question too
right so if the attacker moves the funds
to two different addresses you can
definitely follow the money and see
where the addresses are but you know the
attacker might actually just leave the
funds in in on the blockchain and never
actually translate them to a physical
entity so right that could still then if
there's no interaction with the physical
world you're not gonna you're not gonna
figure out who what the physical entity
is associated with a particular address
right so you know the funds are just
sitting there maybe in a couple of
decades some of someone will withdraw
them but right now they're just there
and we have no idea who they belong to
great yeah this last questions yeah last
question might be a very timely question
so by definition there is no privacy how
does this play into privacy laws oh my
god hahaha okay so let's just be listen
be precise here it's not quite you see
there's no privacy in the blockchain
that's not quite true that's not quite
true so in the Bitcoin system as is yes
when you put data on the blockchain the
whole world can see it when you make
transactions the whole world can see the
transactions the work that I described
here basically allows you to protect the
amounts yeah so still you would know who
paid who but the amounts will be hidden
there are other block chains like Z cash
like Manero that actually protect
everything yeah they're completely
private
so
in Z cache for example you have no idea
who's paying who what the amounts are
just nothing is hidden all you can do is
you can verify that transactions are
valid but you have no idea what's in the
transaction so Z cash actually is a very
very good 4-bit fit for business needs
if you wanted to transact with your
supplier and not even reveal who your
supplier is you know Z cash is a good
way to do it
so to say that there's no privacy it's
just not true yeah there are block
chains that do provide a very strong
notion of privacy it's just that the you
know the most widely used ones Bitcoin
aetherium and so on act of fundamental
layer they don't provide privacy but
again you can build things on top of
them that will provide privacy as well
so yeah so this was me let's make let's
make sure we're precise and accurate
they're great well thank you so much for
your time today Dan and we hope you all
enjoyed this presentation about crypto
and block chains and if you have further
questions please reach out to our client
services team have a great rest of your
day yeah thanks everyone this was a lot
of fun and feel free to send send us
more questions
you